bild exklusiv im frauengefängnis der
taliban unser reporter paul ronzheimer
ist nach afghanistan gereist und hat das
frauengefängnis von herat besucht und
was er dort erlebt hat ist wirklich
schockierend
das frauengefängnis von hier rate in
afghanistan ein grausamer ort voll
verschleierte frauen verängstigt
verschämt auf den boden schauen der
grund sie sind der taliban ausgeliefert
und ihnen ist bewusst im schlimmsten
fall droht ihnen die steinigung bild
vize paul ronzheimer hat einen einblick
in die grausame welt des taliban
frauengefängnisses bekommen findet ein
frauengefängnis das und italien waren
wir unbedingt zeigen wollten sie sagen
sie haben mehr als 80 frauen eingesperrt
weil sie außer jährliche beziehungen
hatten sowie das formuliert recht so
haben sie uns erklärt sei es so dass
wenn beide single war sie dann heiraten
müssen aber wenn es andere partner
gegeben hat dann gibt es hier die strafe
gefängnis das kann bis zur todesstrafe
gehen so erzählt es sonst die tage
es sind grausame qualen unter denen die
eingesperrten frauen leiten müssen der
häufigste grund für die inhaftierung
ehebruch was dann für ein drakonisches
strafmaß droht schildert der
gefängnischef folgendermaßen
das strafmaß für ihr buch wird von
unserem gericht entschieden wir sind
muslime und entscheiden anhand des
islamischen gesetzes bei ehebruch können
dass bis zu 80 bei schnäbel seien bis zu
20 frauen sind im gefängnis von hier
rate in einer zelle eingesperrt reden
dürfen sie nicht das ist die auf seen
here sie sagt
die situation im gefängnis ist besser
als unter der alten regierung weil jeder
jetzt hijab trägt und islamische bildung
bekommt jeden tag würden richter in das
gefängnis kommen und an den fällen
arbeiten
wenn beide seiten die ungesetzliche
beziehungen miteinander hatten
unverheiratet sind dann müssen sie
sofort heiraten und kommen frei wenn
eine der frauen einen ehemann hat und
eine ungesetzliche beziehung eingegangen
ist dann fragen wir den ehemann wie die
strafe auszufallen hat glauben sie mir
alle sind hier sehr glücklich dass das
islamische emirat übernommen hat und
jeder sein recht bekommt die frauen die
still und voll verschleiert in ihren
zellen sitzen sehen dagegen nicht
glücklich aus wenn sie reden würden
würde alles noch schlimmer werden wir
hingegen reden will ist die anwältin
fossile sie hat als anwältin auch mit
frauen die im gefängnis sitzen
gearbeitet bis die taliban frauen
verboten haben als anwalt zu arbeiten
sie erzählt frauen würden aus allen
möglichen gründen eingesperrt werden
viele sind im gefängnis weil sie auf der
straße mit einem mann geredet haben auch
wird man eingesperrt wenn man das haus
ohne einen mann verlässt an den
checkpoints kontrollieren sie auch immer
häufiger mobiltelefone und chat verläufe
kommt ihnen etwas verdächtig vor wird
man direkt mitgenommen das strafmaß für
die frauen ist barbarisch
auspeitschungen oder steinigung bis zum
tod
exklusive bilder die paul ronzheimer und
sein team mitgebracht haben gestern
abend ist er zurückgekehrt aus
afghanistan jetzt bei uns im studio paul
und die
erste frage ist natürlich wie sie
überhaupt da rein gekommen warum hat man
euch daran gelassen dass kann ich dir
auch nicht so richtig erklären warum man
uns am ende rein gelassen hat wir haben
tagsüber die ganze zeit versucht in
herre hat das ist eine provinz rund eine
stunde von kabul entfernt dort rein zu
kommen dann mit dem gefängnisdirektor
gesprochen tatsächlich ist es so dass in
ihrer eigenen realität leben diejenigen
die dort sitzen die verantwortung haben
die glauben tatsächlich dass sie das
richtige tun weil sie ja nach der
scharia leben und das vorher die
ungläubigen dort geherrscht haben
deswegen sind sie teilweise stolz auch
diese dinge zu zeigen und sagte guck mal
das läuft jetzt besser bei uns also so
absurd das klingen mag für uns dass
irgendjemand fühlen oder sagen könnte
dass das irgendwie in ordnung wäre das
ist bei den taliban so denn diejenigen
die dort jetzt regieren das sind ja die
die jahrzehnte gegen den westen gegen
die regierung gekämpft haben was mich
besonders schockiert hat ich bin immer
noch nicht aufgeführt ist diese aussage
der dame eben in deinem film die
ehemänner entscheiden über das strafmaß
ihrer frauen mit und dass es auch okay
so sagt sie ich meine wie kann das sein
das ist erstens total ungerecht gibt es
da kein gericht was über wahrheit
entscheidet wie läuft das ab das ist
etwas was man hier in unserer westlichen
welt kaum erklären kann denn es gibt
dort kein unabhängiges gericht system
oder irgend etwas in dieser richtung
sondern sie sagen wir leben nach der
scharia wir machen das was nach unserem
recht das richtige ist und tatsächlich
ist es so dass
hat die anwältin und dort ja auch
erklärt es ist jetzt nicht so dass der
ehebruch im klassischen sinne dort
beurteilt wird oder wie auch immer im
islamischen sinne sondern es kann
passieren dass eine frau über die straße
läuft sie redet mit jemanden oder hat
eine sms von einem freund bekommen und
der taliban an checkpoints sagt moment
mal du bist verheiratet du darfst den
nicht angucken und deswegen kommt jetzt
ins gefängnis und dann tatsächlich so
ist es wird dann der ehemann mit
einbezogen der dann mit darüber
entscheiden kann ob die frauen
ausgepeitscht ob sie sogar gesteinigt
werden was ist vor allem in den 90er
jahren gab es zuletzt die teile
angeherrscht haben aber wir hören eben
von menschenrechtsaktivisten dass diese
steinigung teilweise wieder stattfinden
abseits der öffentlichkeit wenn man
sozusagen nicht aufmerksamkeit auch
richtung westen haben möchte dass diese
barbarischen dinge passieren aber sie
passieren also diese aussagen der
taliban dass sie ganz anders geworden
sind dass das nichts mehr mit früher zu
tun hat ist völliger blödsinn dass es
gelogen nein diesen barbarischen mittel
werden weiter ein gekommen die frauen da
jemals wieder raus
das weiß ich nicht ob die frauen dort
wieder rauskommen tatsächlich der
eindruck wir waren dort ungefähr eine
stunde war bedrückend dramatisch da
diese frauen zu sehen sie konnten
wollten natürlich nicht reden weil sie
angst haben dann von der aufseherin vor
den taliban das wenn sie etwas falsches
sagen und es ist an jeder ecke dort
gefährlich du warst vor drei monaten da
bei der machtübernahme der taliban jetzt
wieder was hat sich verändert das deiner
sicht die humanitäre lage ist wesentlich
dramatischer geworden es ist ganz
schwierig für menschen dort zu überleben
zum einen zum anderen habe ich das
gefühl dass das was sie ganz am anfang
nach der machtübernahme zurückgehalten
haben soll ein bisschen zumindest zurück
gekommen ist habe mitbekommen wie es
wieder auspeitschung auch in der
öffentlichkeit gegeben hat wir haben
mitbekommen die leute haben uns erzählt
haben dass am checkpoint menschen
erschossen wurde und auch wir selbst
haben erlebt wie viel eingeschüchtert
werden sollten also als wie dort
recherchiert haben in herat bekam ich
plötzlich auf mein handy auf diesem hier
eine whatsapp von einer afghanischen
nummer einer unbekannten afghanischen
nummer wo dann drin stand paschtu
der boden afghanistans muss von euch
gereinigt werden also mann war
unglücklich über unsere recherchen und
hat dann versucht uns unter druck zu
setzen damit wir angst bekommen und das
land wieder verlassen hat dich das ein
fenster wieder hin ich werde auch wieder
hinfahren natürlich kommt es darauf an
wie unsere kontakte die dinge dort
einschätzen denn das ist ja nicht so
dass ich dort einfach alleine hinfahre
sondern ich habe ein team ich habe leute
mit denen ich mitarbeiter ganz kurz noch
eine frage wie soll die bundesregierung
mit diesen neuen regime das jetzt drei
monate im amt ist und nach diesen
erfahrungen
doch die neue außenministerin annalena
baerbock ich glaube annalena baerbock
hat die pflicht sich gerade für diese
frauen in afghanistan einzusetzen sie
hat sich immer sehr für frauenrechte
ausgesprochen sie hat gesagt sie will
eine feministisch geprägte außenpolitik
machen ich glaube das erste worum sie
sich kümmern müsste ist tatsächlich
afghanistan dass es nicht so ganz leicht
wenn sie muss druck machen auf der einen
seite aber auf der anderen seite dürfen
auch die menschen die unter den taliban
leiden jetzt nicht verhungern weil der
westen sich da raushalten will also es
ist ein ganz ganz schwieriges feld und
ich glaube annalena baerbock muss sich
da dringend mehr darum kümmern